ciao gulluni abilità è quella di parlare
con due voci
contemporaneamente è sempre un po
inquietante però la cosa divertente è
che brava al te lo faccio nell'orecchio
di persone che conosco sussurrando quasi
tipo iii è che torni marinai e simili va
in finale ma in finale
ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di vita buttata il tema della
puntata di oggi è talenti nascosti
questo video è stato creato in
collaborazione con gli amici di tv 8 per
il lancio in italia's got talent il
talent dei veri talenti nascosti che va
in onda ogni venerdì alle 21 e 15
sottovuoto per un tema che parla di
talento della grandezza del nostro
popolo non ho potuto che invitare
all'interno degli studios di casa mia
una persona che riesce a nascondere il
proprio talento come nessun altro mio
fratello gabriele versione da una parte
spiega come fai
ciao c'è sempre qualcuno che fa il bagno
prima che io inizi a girare questi video
e non ce la faccio più l'aria mefitica
irrespirabile c'è uno come fa a fare
delle battute all'interno di questa
camera a gas
questo format fa scappata pharma
l'andare al dr di corpo giornate a tema
buner natura spetta mai storia commercia
niente popò di meno che maurizio
costanzo a dire fate interessati ad
avere leo ti devo molto e neonati
all'attacco adatterebbe terna del
fratello porterà babele anche ma può
espandersi e stato il bagno di robbie
williams maria de filippi e bob 6 motta
ma pensi di avere questa dote poiché
ogni volta che la fascia ma invece ma
non può sbagliare di t il che sta nel
versare un bicchiere rab senza farlo
tipo
questo posso anche svuotare non a caso
se poi non la vuoi più questo guardo
sempre con bravissimo per come fai a
messi dipende la prossima volta cosa ci
porti versi magari la coca cola ogni
cosa di tutti i giorni come vedi per
questo la mia capacità particolare di
riuscire a fare il verso del delfino
bravissima chiara concisa non ha
salutato entrata a gamba tesa a posto
charm la cia ospite niente io fin da
quando ero piccola ho un talento
incredibile che mi serve veramente tutti
i giorni della mia vita nella
quotidianità io so abbaiare non è lei
non può essere
se sei tu ti meriti un golden basel
collage però è che non ci credo è vi ho
mai detto che io so fa il verso del
cavallo adesso fa il verso il maiale
[Musica]
macigno talento è quello di leggere
venti in modo velocissimo riesco a
leggere un libro di 400 500 pagine in
due ore neanche farci ci metto anche
meno io non riesco a rendermi conto
perché io manco allora quanto è un libro
dei 400 brandine 1 mag cioè tu alla fine
arrivati alla fine riesce a capire cosa
eletto io non riesco a leggere un
fumetto the dragon ball
secondo me non lo legge insomma abbiamo
scherzato il conto lo leggi scusami eh
ma te lo godi oddio te lo godi sono
all'asta terribile ma non puoi sapere se
singolo della storia oppure faccio
proprio pronti via
hai capito io questo ha fatto cosa vuoi
dirci quindi si metterà tutti i colori
dei privati molto starnutito uno
spaghetto era molto nominato ospite
abbiamo un occhio comunque non riesco a
guardare in su fini quando succede io
guarda in su o un occhio che va sotto e
una invece dei maneggioni cui allego
foto se ti posso per vedere è quella
dell'occhio
la bara è pazzesco queste su questo è
normale
e io se faccio così guardami guardami a
pagamento con tv a fare questa cosa
perché voglio voglio che siano
screensaver delle persone paralizzate
quindi tutto vero fare però sa che
un'evoluzione molto [ __ ] che può essere
perché qui c'è lo sveglio e quindi
continua a guardare perché l'occhio e
quanti viaggio di carpi qaida e
bellissima un'evoluzione allegati un
video in cui fai questo carne parecchio
ossa del mio corpo ma la cosa più strana
che riesco a rispettare
specchiarmi il pisello sono pubblico non
lo so mi sento tipo strano come come fai
io so che si può rompere trance sono sì
guarisci presto biso scrocchiare il naso
io curiosa fare brano ma lo sai come si
fa doveva l'ha vinta io so scrivere con
la destra e la sinistra
contemporaneamente partendo da uno
stesso punto anni due direzioni diverse
e quindi risultato è che posso scrivere
diciamo allo specchio determinate parole
cosa può scrivere stupefacente nella
scrittura cane oddio il seme la befana
in questo è il mio a lato di iscrivermi
spilungone posso dirti che la tua destra
che va dritta giusta per la sua via fa
schifo perché ancora le analisi scrini
albero ma che cosa riguardo il tuo
albero al contrario
parto dalla premessa che non ha
particolari talenti nascosti se non una
risata molto particolare paragonabili a
spruzzini rane insomma vabbè gallego
passato video e ti faccio complimenti
per tutto quello che fai e per le tante
risate che mi ha fatto fare
grazie mille all'ora che sia un pochino
come vivi tu invece
[Musica]
senatur e montato da brava e multi human
è brava e una visionaria
io ho un talento solo uno e privato
parecchio e so fare il verso della
tartaruga dando si accoppia arrivava
ma come mai sapere qual è un video molto
famoso molto bello quello dell'età ma
anche tu lo fai da te cartelle ma se
dolcissimo ma sono adorabili e brava e
talentuosa per il turismo nel mio potere
la mia particolarità è quella di saper
in italia va perfezione del ragazzino
che hanno degli amplessi degli enti che
poi un mix con la tartaruga c'è con
comunis della barba ruga in ognuno di
noi
il rutto parlato questo è il mio talento
come me farei mai citato della sorella a
guardarti questa clip audio alla quale
più grande fame anche la tua tra l'altro
visto che ti segue da quando lei aveva
all'incirca 17 anni e adesso morte non
scherzo 27 il talento innato che mi
distingue è che riesco ad accettare la
posizione dei capezzoli al primo colpo
in particolare sui maschi non importa se
la persona indossa un giubbotto quanto è
alta quanto e manderà quante piccola io
riesco a indovinare al primo colpo
dove siete lavori ai capezzoli e quindi
niente
un talento veramente inutile la qui c'è
praticamente il mio ombelico la ma è la
scena li dovrebbe quindi è un potere si
noi chiaramente no mio talento nascosto
la capacità di sentire una discussione
di due tre persone che stanno parlando
anche abbastanza lontano da me e
malgrado il chiasso se io guardo due
interlocutori e mi concentro il chiasso
attorno a me si sa nulla essendo solo ed
esclusivamente le loro voci
cioè tu sei la regina dei t dell'altri
vicino a te nessuno e salvo qui dice
avete un talent dai [ __ ] con un
commento
e sento che mi hanno delle fitte al
ginocchio ogni tot ogni magari 33
secondi
vuol dire che il giorno dopo verrà a
piovere polo ma cos'è una fitta continuo
quello che mi fa male il ginocchio per
tanto tempo vuol dire che niente sarà
nuvoloso però riesco a prevedere il
cambiamento del tempo in generale per
viverlo milano quando offrendo battono
le mani velocissimo e ai miei amici far
ridere
niente quindi ti mando il video della
versione rallenti per vedere il
funzionamento del battito delle mani è
il battito delle mani se attivo e ti
rovino
vieni qua
siena è pronto più veloce io lo sostengo
abbastanza morbido che io no io non ci
riesco che un quadro quello che sente il
calore
calma ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine
di questo video io vi rinnovo il mio
invito a seguire i miei amichetti tv 8
con questa fantastica edizione di
italia's got talent
ogni venerdì alle 21 e un quarto e
soprattutto vi invito come sempre a
farmi sapere quali sarebbero loro sono
dei temi che vorreste vedere su questo
canale sempre legati a vita buttata se
non volete perdere nessuno iscrivetevi e
attivate la campanera qua sotto
ringrazio anche gabriele a voi no grazie
a te grazie a toni ci vediamo il
prossimo giovedì con un'altra puntata
si canta tutto